you see dwight's coffee mug sometimes
when he's not here
i try to throw stuff in it know what
let's do this
oh yeah here right paperclips
oh wait this message for dwight
oh oh most honorable pamera
not offensive because that's the way
they talk in movies you headed out
uh we are dwight and i are going to the
big thing so
why don't you have everybody work on
their expense reports and i'd like them
in by the end of the day
okay very good have a great time we will
um did you do the thing i used to do
about the magazines
yeah i changed them to your new address
good the
small businessman yep maxim
american way cracked yes i changed your
cracked magazine subscription
how about uh fine arts
aficionado monthly
no okay well could you get on that
because i don't just read cracked
thank you okay see you soon
hey oscar on these new expense reports
do we really have to go back to last
quarter
yeah it's a terrible system i know
what does 2005 season mean
wait a minute what is this it's a
scoreboard what
kevin and i play this paper football
game when michael's out really
or when we're bored oh my god wait this
goes back two years
we're bored a lot
oh sweet yes so close
i really love the uh paper triangle
flicking and hitting bangs game yeah
we call it hate ball why because of how
much angela hates
it hey do you guys have any other games
sometimes we play who can put the most m
m's in their mouth
you play that you should ask toby to
teach you dunder ball
so that's what the sound is all day
stanley just played thunderball with
toby
how about you you got any games yeah i
got a game it's called work hard so my
kids can go to college
fair enough this scented candle
ando handle which i found in the men's
bathroom room room
represents the eternal
burning of competition
or something it smells like cookies yes
it does
yes it does my friend okay we will be
competing for gold
silver and bronze yogurt lids now the
bronze are
really blue and they're also the back
side of the gold so no flipping
okay on our system
i do play games i sing and i
dangle things in front of my cats i play
lots of games
just not at work you have what is
the national sport of icelandic paper
companies
and i'm blanking on the name could you
help me out pam
jim they refer to it as longkerton
hmm in english box of paper snowshoe
racing
fair enough but i like flonkerton
the thing about jim is when he's excited
about something like the
office olympics he gets really into it
and
he does a really great job but the
problem with jim is that he works here
so that hardly ever happens so
who will be challenging kevin in
flonkerton
anyone i'll do it yes phyllis
phyllis did you just put your foot right
through here
right through the flunk
[Applause]
it's phyllis by
thank you delegate from iceland
wow okay no one else should even try
gold medals
wow
oh who has it refrigeration
ryan
[Applause]
[Music]
why are you playing the national um
anthem
your condos in america
[Music]
what the hell is that those are the
doves
all right how many people a year
do you think get their arms cut off in a
baler
baylor i hardly know her damn it michael
pay attention man
anybody want to take a guess five bucks
says it's over 50.
you really want to bet anybody ever
since march madness ended i am
so bored how many okay you're right ten
people
michael ten people would you like to be
one of them
no don't worry let's just go double or
nothing on what
something out you all talking about 10
really 10. that's your guess you're a
professional accountant
there's like 10 green ones 42.
i'm going to say 50. 51. oh don't be
that
it's a strategy it's called being smart
thank you oh
jesus i don't know how the whole betting
thing started but
it's fun 10. kev's out damn it 47
48 49 jim wins oh that is not fair
he has spent hours up here at reception
with you
hours and hours okay okay
no constantly like for years okay pam
this movie moves to the top of the queue
so number five becomes number four
number six becomes number
five number three becomes number two etc
etc and let's just say that i just sent
back love actually which was awesome
and they sent me uptown girls which is
also awesome but guess what
now i want to see love actually again
but it's at the bottom of the queue
oh no what do i do what i do is this i
go online i go click click click
and i change the order of the queue so
that i can see love actually as soon as
i want to
it's so easy ryan do you really not know
how netflix works
i guess i forgot you're such a gift
ryan well done two minutes 42 seconds
additionally pam you win
10 because she said awesome 12 times and
jim you win five because she mentioned
six romantic comedies
green is eating an apple i found a
potato
hey creed hey
hello
nice i don't know this place as well as
i thought i did
i'm getting cleaned out what are the
odds that this is in any way reel
i'd say like 10 000 to 1.
okay i'd like ten bucks on those odds if
someone gives you
ten thousand to one on anything you take
it
if john mellencamp ever wins an oscar
i am going to be a very rich dude
what about this one it's kind of badass
right
just seems kind of crazy in a way i
might need right now i don't know
oh that's not yours
stanley just drank oj out of my mug and
didn't seem to realize that it wasn't
his hot coffee
so the question has to be asked is there
no limit to what he won't notice
well it's a seven seven-letter word for
purse
satchel no starts with an h
handbag thank you
all right everybody take a seat as you
may have heard
our branch on the planet jupiter is up
eight thousand percent in sales
[Applause]
hold up the clock is slow it is five
o'clock
i will see you all tomorrow bye stanley
love you
so long stanley right everybody
you